- All right, let's round out this hour
with just one more drop
of joy to add to your day.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
A New York woman has taken
her love of art, baking,
and pop culture to new heights
by selling adorable cookies,
inspired by Rainn Wilson,
wishing you a happy birthday.
Then there's this one
inspired by Leonardo DiCaprio
toasting the day.
In fact,
she serves up dozens of
culturally relevant designs.
It's an intricate process
with a super clever
and delicious result, y'all.
We have the owner of Funny Face Bakery
on the line right now
watching on NBC 4 New York.
Everybody say hi to Sarah.
(audience cheers)
What's up Sarah?
- Hey Kelly!
Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you as well.
You are so talented. I love this idea.
How'd you come up with it?
- Thank you.
So I came up with it 2016.
Originally, I wanted
to open New York City's
best cupcake bakery.
About a week before,
I had an idea pop into my head
that a face belonged on a cookie.
So I thought, okay,
I'll do this as like an opening day thing
and it was the primaries going on.
So I did Hillary, Bernie, and Trump.
Opening day comes and people
are going crazy over them.
They instantly sell out.
Everyone's Instagramming them.
Next day, I set up all these cupcakes
and everyone's like
where are these cookies?
So I thought I had to shift my focus more
on like a trend pop culture cookie bakery.
So if you walk into our store right now,
you'll see cookies that are keeping up
with the trends, memes.
Right now we're seeing that
dark humor is really popular.
So we have that cookie of like
the rainbow that says anxiety
and celebrities inspired by
like Taylor, Kim, and Harry.
- Yeah, I love that.
Harry's cookies could be
crazy, wild, and cool.
(audience applauding)
I love his style.
So a lot of work goes into each
and every cookie though, right?
- Oh yeah.
A lot of love goes into them.
So it starts out for like custom cookies.
A customer will send a picture
of a face, an animal, a logo.
Then we have a team of designers
that design the cookies.
And after that's approved,
we make a cookie cutter,
we cut them out.
Then we have a team of colorists
that matches up the colors.
And once that's finished, we
do all the intricate details
like little tiny outlines,
draw like the eyes, the nose.
- Wow.
- So yeah, it's a minimum
of ordering 12 cookies.
For even 12 cookies, it takes
like six to eight hours.
So a lot of love goes into them.
But I do wanna show you a cookie
that I'm really excited about.
- All right.
- It's a Kelly cookie!
- Yeah!
(audience cheering)
I want my cookie! That's amazing!
It is crazy how talented
people are and stuff like that.
I can't draw for anything
like, if to save my life.
That is incredible.
Like the rainbow with
anxiety is hilarious.
It's my favorite one that you've showed,
other than my face. (laughs)
I love them!
And thank you so much, Sarah,
for doing this for everyone.
(audience applauding)
It's such a cool business.
I'm liking your post right now.
All right.
(audience cheering)
I have a little surprise
for someone in our audience,
courtesy of our season long partner Pilot,
pen makers of Frixion,
the go to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show.
There is a check.
It's for a thousand dollars
and it's under someone's seat taped.
So if you wanna look under your seat,
you might have that check.
(drum roll)
(Kelly laughs)
Who's got it? Who's got it?
Y'all are not looking!
It's taped. It's taped up under your seat.
Yeah!
(audience cheers)
Hi! You can stand up!
What's your name?
- Hi everyone. I'm Tiffany.
- Tiffany, how are you
gonna use the money?
- Well, I graduated from
grad school recently. And-
(audience cheering)
- Congratulations! That's awesome.
- Thank you. I'm sorry.
- Are you gonna use it for
more than paying off debt?
- I'm not sure.
Yeah, maybe treat some people.
I have a lot of friends.
- Treat yourself! Yes!
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, yeah.
Maybe come back and go to Universal
when I come back to your show.
- Oh my gosh.
Universal's so fun. You should do that.
(audience laughs)
- Thank you so much.
Sorry, I'm in shock. (laughs)
(audience cheering)
- Alright, thank you to
all our guests this hour.
Derek Hough, Jay Hernandez,
Shawn, Cristina, Alex, Daniel,
Nancy Alvarez, Stuart Moore,
and a special thank you to all our friends
at WESH 2 in Orlando.
Y'all have a great day, and
if it's not, change anything.